say it anyway
today's
and Matthew Lawrence just made their
love Instagram official the couple
shared this cute clip on New Year's Eve
rocking onesies while singing and
dancing to aha's 1985 track Take On Me
The caption hashtag New Year's Eve
Shenanigans hashtag we cute it's like a
lot of stuff going on now a rep for the
TLC singer tells E.T the two are dating
and spent Thanksgiving and Christmas in
Atlanta where Matthew met Chili's family
the rep added that she's worked with
chili since 2005 and has never seen her
this in love she is glowing they are
really cute together
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah safe to say these two are digging
on each other in fact I I really enjoy
it Matthew and Chile previously sparked
romance rumors after they were spotted
in Hawaii together in August at the time
a rep for the singer denied anything
romantic was going on which might be
because Matthew was in the middle of
divorcing Cheryl Burke they didn't
finalize their split until September the
Dancing with the Stars pro filed back in
February after three years of marriage
citing irreconcilable differences I
think it's important just to take
accountability over your own life
because obviously you can't control
anybody and I've learned this the hard
way that people sometimes unfortunately
grow and grow apart and while the split
came as a surprise to many A source told
E.T that the two had been having issues
for a while quote Cheryl has been
leaning on her close girlfriends and
trying to stay busy and go out and spend
time with loved ones the reason why I'm
able to I guess keep some sort of Peace
Within Myself is knowing that we both
tried
um we didn't just give up you know and I
think that it's okay I just you know you
have to accept it for what it is
meanwhile a second source told ET that
the pair's divorce was a long time
coming the last time
and Cheryl she raised eyebrows in August
when she posted that Tick Tock writing
quote when he said he would never talk
to her again yet I found text messages
Viagra and a necklace hidden in a pair
of his shoes the caption the last time
is absolutely right goodbye forever plus
some telling hashtags X's suck the last
time goodbye forever and hope it was
worth it it is lonely you know
especially I'm still living in the same
house you know he moved in with me into
my home there's moments for sure of
sadness and reflection and just wanting
to be able to share your life with
somebody Cheryl never confirmed who that
post was about but leading up to the new
year she shared this clip writing that
she made it through a year that quote
did everything it could to try to break
me adding in the caption that she is
ready to move forward and no longer be
defined by her past quote 2023 let's
show them how it's done
[Music]
and shortly after her ex and Chile made
their love public Cheryl proved she's
unbothered with this post set to BB rexa
and David guetta's track I'm good
writing simply mood
[Music]